[Musik]
unsere grafik melanie hat sich gefragt
warum wir bei heißem wetter eigentlich
weniger jörg unger heute beantworten wir
also mal eine interne frage zunächst
gibt es beim essen einen so genannten
thermischen effekt oder wie man im
englischen sagt thermik aspect auftut
kurz de der scénic effekte food erklärt
sich folgendermaßen wenn wir etwas essen
muss unser körper das gegessene
verstoffwechselt ihnen andere produkte
umwandeln unser partner etwas anfangen
kann zum stoffwechsel gehört unter
anderem auch die fettverbrennung die ich
in diesem video schon mal erklärt habe
das heißt einerseits erhalten wir essen
natürlich energie andererseits
verbraucht unser körper beim essen und
verdauen
der energieverbrauch erhöht sich
gegenüber den grund verbraucht wenn wir
nichts ist und dabei entsteht unter
anderem auch wehren weil proteinen ist
der thermischen effekt übrigens
besonders hoch bei kohlenhydrate und
fette ist etwas geringer raten hat man
beobachtet dass sie bei 35 grad celsius
gerade mal zehn prozent von dem essen
was sie sonst bei 24 grad celsius zu
sich nehmen würden möglicherweise um den
körper nicht durch essen noch weiter
aufzuwerten in der folge beobachtete man
einen starken gewichtsverlust gehören
mitmenschen gibt es keine vergleichbar
konkreten studien aber ich kenne es
zumindest auch dass ich im sommer
weniger hunger hat oder wie geht es euch
aber neben dem thermischen effekt von
essen gibt es noch andere gründe warum
essen im sommer weniger attraktiv ist
erst dieses jahr kam eine psychologische
studie heraus die besagt dass wir bei
hitze
mega hilfe erst mal schlicht und einfach
daran liegen dass uns hitze stress und
stress kann nicht nur appetit dämpfen
sondern ebenfalls die körpertemperatur
erhöht außerdem greifen wir im sommer
natürlich bevorzugt zu kalt im essen
also lieber mal einen salat statt eine
dampfend heiße suppe und jeder weiß dass
salat nicht schmeckt naja aber im ernst
manche wissenschaftler sind der meinung
dass warmes essen prinzipiell
schmackhafter ist bei den höheren
temperaturen die geschmacks und
aromastoffe besser raus und das heißt
vielleicht haben wir im sommer einfach
weniger appetit war kaltes essen nicht
so gut schmeckt und warmes essen zu heiß
ist schön schlau wie es bei euch habt
ihr im sommer auch weniger hunger und
was ist euer sommer nicht mitessen
schreibe es in die kommentare zusammen
mit euren fragen hier sehen bleibt
sicher